la grande loge deux seules françaises
qui comporte 32 mille membres et découpé
géographiquement 36 province répartis
sur l'ensemble territoire métropole mais
aussi un des pays ultra marins et
notamment je suis dans le cadre d'un
voyage qui est à partir de guyane puis
la martinique depuis la guadeloupe pour
rencontrer des frères et être au plus
près d'eux et pouvoir échanger sur
parfois la manière dont ici se pratique
la franc-maçonnerie régulière de
tradition on sait que les francs maçons
sont toujours à la recherche de la
vérité quelle action quelle motivation
ou abandonnés aux martiniquais monop' et
un dans la lutte contre le corps d'école
un pesticide qui a des conséquences à
vos relations
alors c'est justement la caractéristique
de sa maçonnerie deux traditions à la
grande loge régulière dans lesquelles
tous les sujets à caractère politique
religieux et les sujets à caractère
sociétés ne sont pas abordées en loge
donc je ne peux pas répondre à cette
question qui est une question pour nous
un caractère éminemment sociétale dans
lesquels on chaque on laisse chacun de
nos membres ensuite avoir la réponse
appropriée et agir mais en dehors du
contexte maçonniques en martinique à 190
membres qu'elle a été constituée et créé
par un de mes prédécesseurs en 2004 et
nous sommes très très heureux de ce
développement serein dans lesquelles
l'ensemble des frères mccormick et
trouvent leur place dans un système de
perfection vous savez peut-être en effet
que la caractéristique notre grande loge
est de regrouper des maçons quelle que
soit leur couleur leur race leur
religion des éléments d'hommes qui ont
envie de travailler à la gloire du grand
h univers parce que nous sommes avant
tout des maçons croyant en dieu
votre obédience était constituée en 1913
est une tradition de confidentialité
la notion du secret on le vit dans la
démarche initiatique quand nous sommes
reçues apprentis compagnons y mettre
mais nous sommes plutôt de nature en
effet confidentielles
considérant qu'il n'y a pas nécessité d'
exposer
j'irai
beaucoup ce que des sujets sur lesquels
nous pourrions travailler c'est le
secret de dire et de l'initiation
alors il ya plusieurs choses qui nous
différencie d'abord la première chose
c'est que nous sommes une obédience
masculine comme la grande loge féminine
et obédiences féminine
ça c'est le premier sujet deuxième sujet
nous traitons pas de sujets politiques
sociétaux ou religieux parce que sont
pour nous des sujets division or nous
cherchons l'harmonie et surtout il
fondamentalement nous sommes avant tout
des maçons croyant en dieu grand
archipel univers qui notre forme d'une
expression de ce nous appelons la
régularité de ce système